- Okay, let's get to another clip.
We've never shown before.
This is from the
beginning of season three.
We had Shaq here along with
Dan Reynolds who cheats at games.
It wasn't long after our season premiere
when we opened with a hit
by Imagine Dragons.
So clearly I had to start there.
So thanks for writing
On Top of the World.
I love this.
I, I will be honest with you.
I hate working out.
It was like something I did in
my twenties and thirties.
I'm 39, moving on.
And, and, and I.
The only time I work out, though, I love.
I literally listen to
either Jay-Z or Imagine Dragons.
This is no joke.
I go back and forth to yalls music.
Like, I love your music.
It's so fun to work out to,
and it's such a great song.
And we kicked off our
season three premiere with it.
We thought it was fun in New York,
but thanks for writing it.
- Well, yeah.
Well, I wanna say thank you,
because I don't know if you remember this.
But in the very beginning of our band
before we were signed.
I was gonna college at Utah.
In Utah.
I actually got kicked outta college.
Reapplied got into college.
That's a whole another story but.
- Seems like a fun one.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But there, there was a
Utah's got talent competition
that my band entered.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And we won it.
And we got to open for you.
- Oh my God was this
the big festival kind of thing.
- Yeah. Yeah.
It was like an outdoor festival.
- Yeah.
- And yes so we got to open for you.
And that really kicked off
our career in a lot of ways.
So I don't think, I don't
think, Imagine Dragons
actually would be a thing
if it weren't for you.
- What? No.
- I'm dead serious.
- Yes
- That's not true.
But do you wanna know what
I remember from that show?
And I'm not sure if Jason
or some of my band will remember this.
This is a real story from that show.
We were in Utah.
- Right.
- And it was outside.
And I don't know if
you'll remember this too.
This girl, I kept looking at her,
and from the audience.
And I was like, man,
her outfit is strange right?
Like it's moving weird.
And I was like, oh my God,
she was in body paint.
Like she was naked
just in body paint.
And what was moving
was like, you know, her goods.
And like, and I was like, and I kept
and she was like, Kelly.
Like just so into it.
And I was like, does she think I'm kiss?
Like, does she think I'm like
like who does she think
is up here right now?
Like I'm a total pop star.
Like not a rock
and she's full on naked
just body painted.
That's what I remember from that show.
- That was, that was me.
- I didn't see you.
- No, it was a girl
- That was me.
- I'm like completely sure it was a girl.
I was like, why is her
outfit moving weird?
Those are her boobs.
What? And I was like, what?
It was a, I was like,
are you allowed to do this in Utah?
Utah's a fun place.
I was like, it's very free.
Anyway. It was a fun show, that show.
There's no segue Dan for that.
Is it true that your daughter talked
to you into doing career
day at her school?
Is that true?
- That is true.
I, you know, I
- That's intimidating.
- Yeah. It's one of those
things where you're,
and I'm sure that you've
dealt with things like this.
But you don't like.
I want my daughter to have a really normal
you know life with school.
I don't want people to
look at her differently,
because her dad is who her dad is.
But.
- Yeah
- So she came home
and asked me to come do a career day.
Which I'm already.
I'm an introvert.
I really don't go out very often.
And the thought of that actually
gave me crazy anxiety to go
to a school of kids
and be like, hello I'm Dan
from Imagine Dragons, blah, blah.
Like Radio Active.
Like for me I was like, oh my gosh.
But on the same note
I was not gonna say no
because of what I do.
So I said.
- Yeah
- I thought about it.
And I said, yeah, yeah,
I'll come do this.
And when I went and met the kids
it was really cool.
Because kids love Imagine Dragons.
They come to all like shows of
Imagine Dragons really range.
It's like family affairs.
- Yeah.
- So I went and of course like
the first question was like
can you sing this song acapella?
And this.
Which is like everything I hate to do,
but so it's the kids.
- Laughs
- So I did it.
- You're having a full on panic attack.
- Which I really was.
I really was
- Oh my gosh.
But, but after me was
a guy walked in from NASA.
And so all the kids were like
who cares?
Get out of here Imagine Dragons guy.
- He's he's gone to space.
- He builds rocket ships.
So I was like okay
this worked out.
- That's so funny.
I wouldn't have pegged
you as even like first
when we first talked,
like after your show.
You're such an extrovert to me.
- I am on stage.
I feel really free on stage,
but I really like when it comes
to everything outside of that, I.
- Yeah
- I've had the same like two friends
since I was, you know
12 years old.
And I never, I never really go out much.
So that's why, you know, Shaq is my friend
since I've been 12.
- He's one at 12
- He's one of my two friends, so.
- He is one of the two.
- It's the only reason I
came on today is I knew
I knew that my friend would be here.
- Thank You, thank you.